i think we're seeing like a big increase
all around
you know the different segments not only
on the automotive but in banking
insurance critical infrastructure
uh you know small even small and medium
enterprises are being hacked
and
and cyber security becoming like hot
topic on board calls and board meetings
in in many of the companies and
companies are spending more and more
money to secure themselves
and i think this is especially where
everything becomes connected
and this becomes more and more essential
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel and in media
partnership with ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
and hello you have levi co-founder and
ceo of upstream security javi's leading
upstream strategic direction culture and
business execution with over 17 years of
experience in multinational high-tech
companies and startups he brings rich
leadership experience in management
marketing and business development of
i.t and security products spanning over
a dozen years of experience in category
leading vendors such as checkpoint
juniper networks and broadcom
you have levy welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm all good thank you very much how are
you doing
i'm doing great thank you so much for
joining me you're the co-founder and ceo
of upstream security but your
your entrance to the cyber security
world is you know it's for a long time
now whether it's with amazing companies
uh like checkpoints and many many others
uh
growing with different positions uh
particularly in the r d space but but
now also as an entrepreneur and i'm
excited to hear both your journey but
also about
the about the automotive fleet space and
cyber security with with the cars and
fleets and and and how does that impact
you know the car manufacturers the
people that are working with the cars
how is it impacting you know perhaps the
you know where the world is heading in
terms of cyber security with vehicles
and so a lot for us to dive into you
tell me a little bit about yourself and
and and how do you find yourself so into
the cyber security space
yeah thank you very much for inviting me
so um
so i i actually started my career in the
early days of this cyber days like more
than 20 years ago uh
working for checkpoint uh in its early
days uh i think even before the they
were using the word cyber
calling like firewall
cyber was not being used so so common in
this time and actually met my partner
jonathan that time
um so and and i spent my career in in
different
startups and and corporates around cyber
security data analytics uh different
positions r d marketing product
um and i think that i i always like i
would say two thing one was my last two
cars i really love cars and and the
second is around cyber and i thought
when i'm gonna do something myself it's
gonna be the combination between the two
so this is like how we got up with the
idea around
uh
yeah you know connected vehicles could
be could be uh
could be dangerous if if they're like
someone hacking a vehicle a connected
vehicle while it's driving that could be
a safety issue
uh who is going to be responsible on
that uh especially you know when cars
are becoming much more complex so some
of them are calling them like computers
on wheel so you can see in the tesla on
on the on the on the right side
uh which uh like you know super
uh super advanced you can see uh
autopilot uh you can see connectivity ev
uh everything is configured and
everything could be done remotely
uh there are they're actually able to
solve issues
remotely by doing over their update and
and this is where we came up with the
idea about upstream and about the need
to secure the connected vehicles
okay so
we're almost
we're almost five years ago when when
upstream security starts and and this is
obviously an interesting timing because
this is when i think a lot of the hype
in the bus around autonomous vehicles is
beginning right so i guess that that was
an interesting uh timing for you to also
think through these ideas but please
continue
yeah exactly so so we started the
company uh 2017
uh and when we started the company we
saw other companies that are trying to
solve exactly the same problem around
how do you make
the vehicles more safe and more secure
around the connected vehicles and as
well as autonomous vehicles
and so forth and and when we looked at
at the other companies in india we said
we believe we should solve this problem
in a different way
we we believe that we can solve the
problem without deploying any software
or hardware inside the beacon especially
when we spend some time when we started
before we started the company talking
with car companies or talking with tier
ones when we said
this is a very complex
process of adding hardware software
inside the beacon that could take years
and when we when we looked at other
companies that were very successful like
mobile and other it took them like you
know seven ten years together the first
vehicle on the road with their
technology and said uh we don't have the
dna of waiting too much time before
getting to production we have uh you
know we have uh
uh we're impatient people we want to see
results immediate so and this is when we
came up with the idea about actually
building a cloud technology
which means that you know once we deploy
the technology uh we can start
monitoring the monitoring the connected
vehicles start looking at data anomalies
uh
and combine the two things that we love
the most
uh cyber security and data
and vehicles
and this is how we came up with the idea
about upstream
so then obviously there's different
challenges that you're presented with
one of which is the manufacturers and
how do you actually integrate with the
cars you mentioned before that it's not
simple to just
put hardware software within the cars
and
long sales cycle long manufacturing
cycles how do you go about solving them
is leveraging leveraging the cloud
right so so think about upstream as like
an after sales type of solution like a
solution that is not getting into the
production cycle of the vehicles so
there is a production cycle
that you know you have to design
vehicles you have the suppliers
to you know assemble the vehicle test it
it can take many years
we are actually like a cloud solution an
i.t solution that we deployed in the
cloud
of the car manufacturers sometimes they
call it like oems
or the fleet owners and and what we're
doing we are leveraging data that these
companies are already collecting from
their vehicles so we're only talking
about connected vehicles
uh we're only talking about uh
services that are running on top of this
connectivity
and we leverage the data that is already
being collected in order to run
data analytics or security analytics on
the data in order to find anomalies that
could be indication of compromise
indication of attack and we're now
actually building additional
applications beyond cyber security that
that can help us to detect anomalies
that are related to failures of ecu's
which are like computers inside the car
or failures of different systems in
inside the car and maybe also in the
future we will build a predictive
maintenance the ability to predict these
faders so what we're trying to build
here is a very strong data platform
purpose built for the automotive market
that will help our customers on one hand
to secure their connected vehicles but
on the other hand also to monetize their
data
so taking back to the founding of
upstream security you want to deal with
cars you want to deal with autonomous
vehicles and how do you even get started
how do you get started trying to even
test to see whether a poc that you've
built works how does one even enter
enter a market like this
yeah
yeah so so
first we actually went and did like a
market validation so we talked to many
of these
car manufacturers still ones fleet
owners and
and we saw that this problem is
something that there are you know there
are people that call like csos the chief
security officers
where part of their responsibility is
also to make sure that the vehicles are
secure so i said okay this is good news
with someone that is actually care about
securing their vehicles
and uh and if you think about
essentially you know
what we're doing we're actually securing
the product that the company builds it's
not securing their data center
it's actually securing their product and
securing the company itself
and uh so what we have done we have done
some uh
market validation that included like you
know small plcs different uh uh you know
different conversation that we had with
prospects
and then we went and we saw okay there
is a great potential here let's go and
raise money
and uh and we raised our seed round uh
four and a half years ago from uh two
venture capitals glilat capital and uh
manila which are great partners from day
one to the company uh amazing help that
we're getting from these uh vcs
um up until now we've done
four financial rounds we
we have just completed our c round we
haven't announced it on e on it yet
but uh i would say that the c round is
significantly high amount of money we're
going to announce in the next couple of
weeks
which is great so the company is well
financed uh
and uh
yeah this is this is like how we started
and so where are you today positioned
with with the car fleets and with the
technology
where is upstream security today in the
world
yeah so so upstream today is definitely
the leader in in this segment
now we created the segment of automotive
cyber security cloud-based we're leading
this segment and today we have many car
manufacturers that we have a production
and commercial agreements with which
means you know multi-year commercial
agreement
real vehicles
on the roads we have millions of
connected vehicles that we are
monitoring today as part of our platform
both in the us in europe as well as in
japan
uh
and and it's actually growing so we
expect to get uh
actually double digit of millions of
vehicles uh by by uh next week next year
sorry so this is uh
each of our customers
are actually growing the number of
vehicles they have uh organically
because they are manufacturing more
connected vehicles but also
uh we're adding new new customers so so
upstream by the way we have
uh
three large car manufacturers that
invested in the company the renault
nissan mitsubishi called the alliance
volvo group and hyundai group
but we also have other customers as well
other than
the one that invested in upstream
so so once you have you know these three
organizations invest back in upstream
how does that impact your ability to not
obviously with it with the finances
you're able to then scale up your
operations but but how does this
partnership impact the way that you then
position the product think be able to
validate what what happens from that
point on
yeah so so you can think first you know
it's a bit strange right you see
companies that are competing with each
other that investing in the same company
which is not very common right because
sometimes you know you want a company to
invest to you so they want some kind of
exclusivity but i think that for cyber
security this is this is a different
because
what the car manufacturers are actually
want is that we will have a lot of
customers so we will gain a lot of
knowledge and insight from the industry
and then we can secure them better and
we can do a better job
so this is one thing the second is
around
you know in in the automotive industry
it's it's uh
uh
having a car manufacturer invest in you
it's a good sign of credibility
uh that
sometimes startups in this domain needs
uh
mainly because you know there are
hundreds of different maybe thousands of
different startups in the autotech
industry
now who's going to walk with you know
with these large oems they need to pick
one partner right
uh
better chances if we have you know
three or actually five car companies
and there are no nissan mitsubishi volvo
and honda invested in upstream and we
have other customers that are doing
reference call for us
to win you know new accounts so
from their perspective you know
seeing
uh so many you know strategic investors
invested in upstream
uh is a good sign for credibility
right so
as
cars are becoming more intelligent
moving to the cloud the connectivity are
you are you also thinking about other
verticals perhaps that other young
entrepreneurs can examine where else is
the world shifting where cyber security
is going to have to play an interesting
role in the development of these
connected devices
yeah so we're looking at two different
segments today one of them so one of the
companies that led our c round
called mitsui sumitomo insurance it's a
very large
japanese insurance company
and we actually have another insurance
company called nationwide it's a
us-based insurance company
and the reason they're invested in
upstream
is because our knowledge in connected
car data and uh
and how this data can be used
for insurance use cases both on
understanding better the risk around the
driver like how do you drive
maybe we can build a specific pricing
for you based on your driving experience
sure and second is like how do you
handle claims like can we
help you to be more efficient during the
claim process
uh by using your connected car data and
you know detect car accidents in our
platform
um
and help them to uh
actually uh you know becoming more
efficient in this area as well improving
the customer experience and so forth
so definitely insurance is is an area
that we started building our technology
and solution
and the other thing that we're looking
at
is smart mobility a bit wider than just
vehicles vehicles is definitely where we
put like 90 percent of our effort today
but we started to look at
other things like uh
uh you know everything that moves we
call it smart mobility you know that
could be
connected drones connected boats
connected the trains uh
row boats whatever everything that moves
and provides some kind of service
and this is on our vision where we are
going to go uh next
yo tell me a little bit about your your
relationship with cyber cyber security i
think i know outside of outside of
israel
it's it's not that common to be working
in the cyber security space
what what is it about cyber security
that really gets you going you've been
in this space for from almost two
decades now what what is it
yeah so first i i really like the
defensive part like uh
um you know
i think we're seeing like a big increase
all around
you know the different segments not only
on the automotive but in banking
insurance critical infrastructure
you know small even small and medium
enterprises are being hacked
uh
and uh and cyber security becoming like
hot topic on board calls
and board meetings in in many of the
companies
and companies are spending more and more
money to secure themselves
um and i think this is especially where
everything becomes connected
and this becomes more and more essential
uh
and becomes like
something it's not like nice to have
like it used to be like maybe a few
years ago this is something that is
mandatory
and and i think what's really attract me
around cyber
is um
is is the ability actually to help you
know the organization to run their
business
smoothly
and
and uh and actually this is something
that we understand and know you know
best from all other areas so
you know doing cyber for 20 years
from the early days starting from the
bits and dice you know in firewall
network firewalls going into application
level and now going into you know more
complex big data and security analytics
solution this is uh this is what i do
best
amazing okay so i want to take you back
onto your childhood before you
become a cyber security expert what
really fascinates you what really sparks
your curiosity
um
yeah it's i think it's a good question
uh
so
i i think that you know putting aside
you know the
you know the startup what's really
interesting me is
i really love sport i really love
surfing i'm actually a
wave surfer kite surfer
now i'm doing like stand-up pallet
boards surfing on waves and paddling
actually love it i'm trying
the reason i love it is because you can
actually do it very early in the morning
and before you know before you actually
go to work
uh
so so this is this is uh something that
i uh i love you know in startup days you
have less time so you need to be more
efficient it's not like you know there
is wind i can i can drop everything and
go to the beach unfortunately right uh
but uh
but i i this is like something that they
loved
am amazing and if you look today and the
things that inspire you to continue
working so hard and drive this company
forward you know whether it's personal
or professionally what really inspires
you yeah i'm yeah i'm actually watching
you know the olympics yeah actually at
the end of every day in the olympics i i
watch the summary
uh
and i'm looking at these athletes and
i'm inspired like you know they're
devoting their life to
you know becoming a pro and the medal
olympic
and
you can see like what they're doing this
is like
so inspiring and saying wow how this you
know
this is what they're doing
from when they were like five years old
to now you know such a dedication
and and you know mental mental strength
and uh
i think it's amazing so
you know just remind me about you know
i'm looking at these these athletes and
and this is really inspiring
i love it and what are three words that
you would use to describe yourself
yeah you know in hebrew it's called
taktakan but i think that in english is
like get things done
uh
not always like perfect but i get i
usually get things done
i love it so it's getting things done
yeah getting things done
i i love it great you have to dab thank
you very very much this was a really
really great and i'm happy to hear about
the amazing progress of stream security
and making connected cars be more secure
makes me feel a little bit safer for
when i'll drive in a connected car
hopefully in the next few years and so
best of luck and thank you for the
inspiration for the time and stay safe
and stay healthy
thank you very much and thank you very
much for inviting me
[Music]